skel one got canceled at least in terms
of uh you know like being released from
Microsoft I guess there's no word on
whether it could ever happen again
well Microsoft owns the IP so that won't
happen again probably not I mean what
they're we'll get to this but they're
courting phantom dust around I mean yeah
so just as a primer if you don't know
scalebound at e3 2014 was showing off
it's a co-op action game Platinum was
developing it people who made Bayonetta
you know Metal Gear Rising revengeance
and they're working on Nier automata
right now which I want to get into but
it's weird that at the Microsoft III
2014 press conference it was project
spark phantom dust remake crackdown 3
and this game scalebound
yeah product sparks released to little
fanfare phantom dust remake is now a
thing that's supposed to come out this
year but for a while is kind of in
hiatus crackdown 3 no one knows what's
going on with that and now you have
scalebound which is canceled
Microsoft their statement it was
originally like a report by Kotaku or a
room every time a bunch of people
confirmed that what not a Microsoft said
after careful deliberation Microsoft
Studios has come to the decision to end
production for scalebound
we're working hard to deliver amazing
line-up of games to our fans this year
though including Halo Wars 2 crackdown 3
state of decay to see if thieves and
other great experiences sounds kind of
like a defensive statement like people
like I am reading into it saying what is
going on with Microsoft you know they
have the Scorpio on the horizon in terms
of hardware but what's going out with
software I'm reading into it as
Microsoft Studios has decided we no
longer want to make Japanese games but
we have a lot of exciting western games
to look forward to in the future like
it's it's no secret that Western and
Eastern companies have you know
different styles of developing games and
we see a lot of games from Japan get
delayed like that's a thing that happens
quite a bit scalebound itself has is it
been at least one official delay before
the cancellation something like that
because you have 2016 and 2017 because
of quote from Microsoft a crowded
holiday release schedule yeah like
that's such that's such BS but what did
you so you heard that there wasn't it
part of the rumors that right like the
developers had gone on this break
because of development branch yeah the
the rumor was that it was too strenuous
so like the top developers went on a
break for a month and then when they
came back or shortly after they
came back it was decided that hey we're
gonna cancel this game but I think if
you look even a few months back the
president of Platinum Games I believe
I'm getting his position correct I'm
sorry I remember his name but he left
the company he left the company after
probably two years of it sort of
changing its MO right where it used to
be these one-off like great action games
and he started taking all this license
stuff that they were gonna make and is
it that surprising to see him leave and
then see scalebound end up cancelled
like I'm not that surprised by that yeah
I think that there might be a connection
not directly to that but some sort of
you know by proxy like yes the problems
that led to scale bands cancellation you
know that platinum is responsible for
not Microsoft where the platinum is
perhaps that is you know part and parcel
for why this guy laughs and I'd really
don't know so don't take me for my word
but it just seems like what a perfect
storm yeah back in April of this year
Japanese game and she's like game
business announced that yeah president
plenum games Tatsuya Minami right up
down yeah it just it's weird we're
talking about Mass Effect Andromeda
later and all the studio departures and
you know crises that happen during the
development of that and who knows how
that's going to turn out March 21st the
release day now but yeah you have to
wonder between the delay from 2016 and
2017 I personally was not that impressed
with the e3 2016 demo they showed for
those of you watching right now it's the
I was that co-op fight against that
giant crab boss I mean and it looks
impressive yeah in terms of scale no pun
intended it seemed you know massive
right like the scope of it seemed pretty
huge and the idea of coop seemed really
cool yeah it just it struck me as like a
co-op Devil May Cry or something similar
yeah but the execution just didn't seem
like at least in the demo right it's
like suppose to be this big opening
world and it's like hey here's a boss in
an enclosed area and it's gonna be kind
of a slow fight yeah like oh that
doesn't it doesn't ring platinum to me
that doesn't ring open world you know
co-op RPG did anyone get a chance to
play this had they done any demos or no
only behind closed doors stuff and I
don't even think with press yeah so this
is the question I wanted to ask is what
does this bode for Microsoft in terms of
like first party titles Jacob tough on
Twitter actually that's the same thing
with this being continuing or sorry he
had a couple tweets so previous
direction or in the blind forest was
also showed at to them III 2014 so
one of those games came to fruition and
I love that game
so yeah Jacob tuff said back in 2014
Phil Spencer was saying how there will
be tons of new games for Xbox one
three years later they're still coasting
on game announcements from 2013-2014 and
in that time games of a canceled in
multiple Studios closed Lionhead fable
legends with this being a continuous
trend how worrying is this for the
future of Microsoft first party
offerings in the long term not even
though in the long term I mean we're
talking about again talking about this
in a later segment what's our game
prediction for this year I would assume
halo 6 will be announced here's where
Ford just came out gear 2 or 5 will be a
thing because that's what the coalition
under Rod Fergusson is working on here
we are stretching to come up with like a
handful of titles but we also put an
article out the other day and I'm not
playing a fanboy here mr. stating facts
you know PlayStation 4 exclusive for
2017 it's like over 35 games in there
yeah and you look through that listen
it's like yep sounds good yep sounds
good man I wonder what that is like it
all looks super promising Sony's also
taken a lot of risks and followed
through on them right so I think that
speaks to a different sort of behavior
and outlook for the two companies
Microsoft has made a bigger push into
the PC space not not huge not like
game-changing but enough to maybe
indicate or signal that they don't see
the console business the same way that
Sony does anymore right for Sony it is
like a huge pillar for their business
from Microsoft I guess I don't know
offhand but when you look at this sort
of you know the activity around it it
doesn't seem to be the thing that is
like representative of Microsoft in
everyone's eyes what is for Sony like
PlayStation is really I think yeah no I
mean like after oh sorry no no no yeah
so I just think that they're they're
forking they're taking a different path
it was weird because back like mid
summer late summer when the ps4 Pro and
the ps4 slim were announced and
everything and then you know Scorpio we
knew the Scorpio is gonna be essentially
when it releases this year it felt like
Microsoft's not to just look at it in
terms of competition but if I like
Microsoft kind of had the upper hand in
terms of you know like public visibility
at least in terms of hardware again but
yeah now we're getting into the year and
Scorpios in the horizon but like you
just said we don't have much else to
just say hang our hats on scalebound
however it looked pretty cool and
slightly promising but I wasn't
particularly looking forward to it but
now that that's gone I mean if you know
if you just wanna talk about
PlatinumGames they released Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles mutants in
Manhattan which was kind of a bust right
they also did the well they have Nier
automata coming up and that's kind of
the next upcoming title they have two
others in the works right now or at
least announced granblue fantasy
projects relink and lost order but Nier
automata is the next upcoming one which
I played and I'm really excited for it
looks good and it feels good so except I
want to be excited for lost order
because as someone who loves Final
Fantasy Tactics mots and a son and a few
other people who had made Final Fantasy
Tactics are making lost order under
platinum it's like a perfect talk about
for another perfect storm Ike it sounds
so great but it's a mobile game plan
tomorrow they did yeah so what was going
on I don't know but so back to Microsoft
though right like they face a huge
uphill battle with Scorpio because at
the beginning it was like all about
we're the most powerful right but what
does that actually equate to now granted
it's gonna be more powerful than ps4 Pro
like that seems to be the way it's gonna
pan out but look at what happened with
the reception for ps4 Pro it kind of
came out people were excited for a
minute and then they realized like crap
like maybe it's not hard for developers
but as a player I'm realizing that this
thing gives me too many options and the
games across the board don't support
every option so a ps4 a Pro has been
kind of divisive and I think that's
maybe set off Microsoft to have a bit of
a challenge when they released Scorpio
because is it just gonna be that same
thing all over again right yeah people
who've been watching from the sidelines
with Pro like they might say well I'm
not gonna make the same mistake again or
I've I've already seen other people make
this mistake and so if they don't have
power being the thing that's gonna sell
the console has to be games yeah it's
just the same old games and they're also
on PC like yeah I know that's the thing
like I mean I'm excited for Halo Wars
too but am I gonna play that on my xbox
probably not yeah because I mean it's an
RTS first of all it makes more sense on
PC but like I don't know like especially
like Forza horizon I got Forza horizon 3
not that long ago and I played on my
xbox a little bit and I just switched to
PC I was like I looks better than this
and like with cross save and everything
like it'd be great to say you know the
Xbox would make an awesome extension for
PC gaming but I don't know that a lot of
games that really thrive in PC could you
know work on a console and there's
already a lot of crossover like when a
game makes sense its multi-platform now
it's on PC already so Mike doesn't
really have that advantage to look
forward to or even planned for the other
two games they mentioned state of decay
to which I'm excited for Becky was right
I mean that game sounds cool
yeah like the first one was great but it
was pretty technically flawed yeah so
hopefully this one they can iron out the
issues that but it's not that massive of
a game and just kind of you know peg
your plan on like a halo six or
something which again I'm I think
that'll be announced this year and you
know they need some of those first party
titles gears were five I don't know when
will actually seem thing in that four
we're still on the you know tail end of
fours release they also mentioned sea of
thieves rares game right I've played it
a few times they only showed us
bite-sized elements it's that it's a
first-person the MMO kind of cartoony
part style pirates yeah and I'm I don't
see myself playing that for very long
yeah and a flag flagship title it seems
like a really cool idea but like I feel
like all the stuff they act out in demos
and trailers like I'll play online and
people are just gonna be jerks when is
it supposed to come out that's kind of
soon yeah cuz halo wars 2 is right
around the corner next like next month
state of decay - I don't believe they've
announced the actual specific day see if
thieves will be it just says 2017 but I
think it's soonish I don't know I don't
think they should be saying by now yeah
this late into development if it's if
they're not putting a date on this year
yeah
weren't there rumors - that's like
something about fable like they might
try to bring back fable or something
like that like fable legends was
cancelled but then they were saying like
maybe there's some way to revive it in a
different form but cuz I think it's
beneficial moving in like with even
fable legends like I don't think anyone
was that bum that that got cancelled
because it's not what people wanted with
a fable game so I don't know like I
think if they relaunch fable into like
an RPG like it was originally intended I
mean originally made I think that could
be something that people would be
interested in but I don't know basically
as a crackdown and fan I would like
crackdown 3 to kind of see the light of
day sometime this year yeah it sounds
like in their statement they're saying
it will but who knows maybe that'll be
will that be as late as an e3
announcement then they'll say hey it's
the reason this fall or they do
something sooner
I hope they would do something sooner I
think it would benefit them so they
would have some sort of confidence going
into the late summer and fall releases
I'm sure that game
a good candidate to tighten a Scorpio
because one of the things about that
game it's actually not related to the
console it's related to their servers
but that game has like real-time
destructibility in incredible
environments which if they were able to
say I don't like with a look at this can
do and we're playing it on Scorpio even
though it's being run off you know off
the cloud yeah I could see that as being
the right time for them to sort of be
like yeah and here's this game yeah I
mean it would benefit them that I think
to have like it's not a brand new
console but it's silly like you know
having people like games to launch with
the Scorpio it's a stable I mean the
consoles are a statement and Scorpio is
a statement it's just not like a new one
it's a revised yeah yes I mean for all
intents purposes right now Xbox his
future with the Xbox one is sort of
cloudy but you know hopefully in the
coming months or though coming weeks
they actually figure things out or show
us that they have figured things out or
I don't know remember when recore was
supposed to be great yeah I keep there's
a lot of promises and a lot of hope but
I don't know quantum break know
something about quantum break no we
shouldn't I feel like I've already
badmouth Microsoft enough yeah anyway so
yeah that is we talk about the
scalebound cancellation without platinum
games they have Nier automata coming up
in a couple months time but yeah so what
do you think about the Xbox ones future
let us know whether you are a Sony
fanboy a PC fanboy xboxone fanboy I'm
stoking the flames and we need more
comments take a fanboy or a second
fanboy yeah let us know the comments
below what you think about the Xbox ones
future
[Music]